Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
you did some guys who just get trapped
in a persona.
We were just talking about emo phillips
the other night cause emo phillips is
apparently back to his persona.
He let it go for a long time and he just
started just being a guy on stage
talking about shit.
Apparently the people weren't into that.
He's like,
all right,
give the people what they want.
By the way,
I should just clarify this is,
which is what I've heard.
I haven't seen him,
but this is like,
um,
you know,
robin was a,
when he was,
was my best pal and,
and uh,
he got me a job on,
on,
uh,
a snickers commercial and I needed bread
and he was so nice.
He's like,
Oh,
you know,
so I want you to use my friend Bob cat.
You know,
he's gotta be in it,
you know,
and like,
and they're like,
you know,
he actually put their feet on the fire
and they had to hire me.
And then he goes,
he's like,
don't take the first money.
Just the way,
you know,
tell him no,
I tell him no.
And then they came back with more and
when you know,
I mean he was great.
Right,
right.
So then he calls what,
because you know they're going to want
you to do the voice.
Are you okay doing the voice?
And I go for the amount of money
snickers is paying.
I will fuck a snickers behind camera.
By the way.
I should say it's a really big candy,
but it's my all time favorite.
You know,
I,
I said I was going to go,
but,
well,
we'll address a little bit and talk
about,
you know,
robin had,
um,
has his coroner's report came out and he
had lewy body dementia and that is a,
it's a form of dementia that is very
rarely ever discovered when someone's
alive.
It's usually discovered in there.
They're a autopsy.
So he had this form of dementia.
I witnessed it.
It was missed a diagnosis.
Parkinson's.
Ah,
and I,
I witnessed this eye witnesses
processing reality completely different
than the way every body else does.
What causes it?
It's,
um,
I'm not sure if it's a gene or what,
but I mean it,
it is,
sadly,
his brain was riddled with this.
And so when I think about that,
I think about how strong he was.
You know,
you would have like some days you'd have
a lot of days where he was doing kind of
ocd stuff and processing things
incorrectly,
but then you'd have a day where he was
back.
So you'd go,
oh well maybe set a bad day or no,
maybe it's the Parkinson's drugs.
And they've got to get those dialed in.
You know,
he had,
he was going to doctors use in therapy,
he was doing,
and it just,
the only reason I talk about that is,
is his brain was giving him
misinformation,
completeness,
Information.
And I don't if some people die from
depression and uh,
and my heart goes out to them,
but that's not what killed him.
He,
he,
he really was getting misinformation
from his own brain and was suffering
from disease.
So I just put that out there because I
folks know that we were friends in
there.
They'll ask me about it.
And,
and,
and I would like a spotlight put on the
disease.
That actually in my mind was what was
responsible for its demise.
Because,
you know,
a lot of people say,
did he ever talk about suicide ago?
Comics,
we talked about suicide for 33 years.
You know,
sometimes we talk about other shit,
you know,
hey,
congratulations on the ASCA.
Oh,
thank you.
How would you do it?
I don't know.
I think a car,
you know,
but I just say that because he fought,
that's what we do.
I don't know about you,
but it comic,
that's what we do.
We fight depression.
Things don't add up.
It doesn't,
this world doesn't seem right.
And we'd go out and we spew,
but it,
and I feel better on a selfish level.
I don't really give a rat's ass,
you know,
I vent and I feel better.
And,
and,
and he fought it.
And that wasn't,
it wasn't depression.
It wasn't career.
It wasn't,
you know,
he'd been sober most of his adult life,
so,
so it was very disturbing to me that a
lot of people were trying to attribute
all sorts of reasons for why he did it.
And even there was a lot of like,
um,
well that's the main thing is rights
groups that were attributing it to his
divorce settlements.
Brother.
Yeah.
There was a whole thing where this guy
was doing this video and I even talked
to him about it.
It's,
he,
he had a disease.
He had a disease that caused dementia
that I witnessed.
I didn't have anybody.
I talked to him more,
you know,
I talked to him and text and every day I
didn't have a buddy that I talked to him
more.
So just to be,
it wasn't a divorce.
It was,
it didn't,
it wasn't as family.
It wasn't,
we have the same agent.
So like when this guy was saying,
this is one of the reason why it pissed
me off because he's guy was saying that,
you know,
he's in financial ruins.
Like,
no,
he wasn't.
No,
he was wealthy.
Yeah.
And also it's,
it's,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
no one wants to,
uh,
because we as human beings,
we're trying to make sense of,
of,
of why w why that happened and why that
happened in my opinion,
which is right,
was his brain was who would know more
than you?
It was his brain was getting,
uh,
misinformation and he was processing
reality completely wrong.
I mean,
I W I won't go into details,
but I did witness him thinking things
that weren't real or happening and to me
in the middle of the night.
And that's the only thing.
Like people say,
oh,
he wasn't in the same bedroom as his
wife.
It's like,
yeah,
because he was having seizures and he
didn't like to wake her up.
Oh God.
It's not a question of somebody not
getting along.
I didn't mean to get so personal.
I don't mean,
and I don't mean to talk about about
his,
uh,
his home life because you know,
Susan's a wonderful Gal and,
and,
and it's just sad,
you know?
No,
it's awful.
That's the one of the scariest things is
I'm talking to someone who's,
whether it's a loved one,
a father,
mother that's losing their grip.
And I think people were s they were
courteous to a point,
but I don't think they,
they take his,
his kids and the consideration and
friends and people worked with them for
all these years.
And I guess I can't expect them to,
you know,
I mean I'm sure I've taken shots at
people when they pass away,
but it's just,
it's like people would come up and they
go,
did you hear?
What did you,
what rush limbaugh said?
And I'd be like,
I don't care what it says.
I'm dealing with people who dealt well
then we had a daily basis.
Let me ask you this,
what is it,
what is this impulse that people have to
denigrate people right after they die?
It's almost like everyone else is,
everyone else is talking about that.
Like I saw a lot of that with prince
when it was revealed that prince was
suffering through opiate addiction.
Yeah.
And I was like,
well there was like even gene Simmons
said some crazy shit.
And he had to apologize.
And I'd seen some other people say too,
but what,
it's almost like it's a crunch,
a contrarian thing.
Like everyone else is saying,
oh you got,
we lost his genius.
Well you get heat from it and I'm sure
in Gene Simmons is,
you know,
I'm sure there's a jealousy thing,
but you say,
look,
I used to say outrageous things about
people and,
and this bomb will go off and I would
get,
I would get some heat and now I get some
buzz and I stopped doing that.
I made a decision,
you know,
realizing that these weren't just a
harmless things I was saying.
Right,
right,
right.
You just,
yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
it was,
yeah.
Cause there are a lot of that when Kurt
cobain died too.
But yeah.
You know,
and that's the way,
I wasn't best these with Kurt,
but I did know him.
I toured with Nirvana,
Kurt,
like my standup and asked me to go on
the road with them.
I did a bunch of date.
No,
we talked about it.
But,
but I,
I mean,
it wasn't like the situation was wrong,
but,
but I did have times in my life where I
spent hours with Kurt when no one else
sitting around talking and laughing,
you know?
Um,
I don't know why we want to do that.
I think,
I think we try to make sense of it.
Trying to make sense of it,
I think.
I think that's where a lot of
conspiracies come from.
I think when,
when someone who's in our mind reached
the American dream and then they die or
look or con or take their life or
overdose,
we have to say,
well,
they had it all.
And that's what we believe is the
ultimate fulfillment and happiness.
You know,
America is like People's Republic of
spring break.
You know what?
No one's pursuing fulfillment.
Everyone's pursuing happiness.
You know,
there's two different things.
I'm really fulfilled.
Am I happy?
Am I laughing?
I don't think I might know.
But you're happy sometimes.
I'm happy a lot of the time.
Yeah.
Well,
I've never,
not top here.
Like,
if I didn't know that you're this nuance
guy that's very thoughtful and you have
a lot of opinions and you're always
considering all sensitive.
If I just took like if I tried to form a
view of you based on you and I talking,
we're always laughing.
Yeah.
I would say bobcat.
So jolly every toddler talking to them
like laughs and hugs and,
but it is true and it's,
and it's uh,
uh,
cause we never see each other before
noon.
First of all,
it's a,
it's a daily reprieve.
It's a daily decision.
You know,
I get up,
the squirrels are up before I do and I,
and I beat him down and then it turns
and when I'm directing on a set,
I'm like,
I can react and fear or I can just sit
here for a second or two and it all,
he's usually works out.
Very rarely do I have to say no man,
this is,
you just sit there.
I think so much of show business,
everything's based on fear and people
thinking someone's going to say,
you screwed up or you didn't do it right
or you didn't get extra takes and all
that stuff.
But man,
my job is really not to to freak out.
I'm really happy right now.
[inaudible] okay.